this is super interesting in the last
few days there have been some tweets
floating around an article saying that
the american right
has now gone from the war on christmas
to the war on thanksgiving as a sort of
replacement to the non-existent war on
christmas that they've been touting for
like a decade at this point
so as a reminder the war on christmas is
supposed hostility to christmas
and two christians that the right says
exists in the united states by the left
and it mostly
this stems from the idea that a few
years ago um
there there have been since a few years
ago there have been many people saying
you know
saying happy holidays is more inclusive
than saying merry christmas when you
don't know somebody's religion
listen if you're a christian and you
know you're talking to a christian say
say merry christmas
it might be more inclusive like at
starbucks for example or maybe at a
place of work or whatever
to say happy holidays that's it that's
the genesis and the catalyst for the
so-called war and war on christmas
that the right has been talking about
now for a decade
we have uh thanksgiving coming up here
in the united states
during a global pandemic and so there
are more and more governors and state
public health officials saying
you really shouldn't have large indoor
gatherings at thanksgiving
that's how the virus spreads and in fact
even at this point in time
most contagion is happening inside
people's homes either between family
members or
friends who are spending time in close
proximity to each other in
indoor spaces we know the virus spreads
more indoors than outdoors
we know that being around someone for
hours rather than minutes is more likely
to spread it
we're closing in potentially on 200 000
cases per day in a few weeks
yesterday we had 1600 deaths so
especially
with vaccines hopefully coming soon it
seems
this is a time to be careful rather than
reckless
so the war on christmas right wingers
have now taken the opportunity to claim
that the left is waging a war on
thanksgiving here's one
short clip this is a guy named charlie
kirk
who shockingly is sometimes promoted by
donald trump and others take a look at
this
the left has always hated thanksgiving
thanksgiving can be interpreted as
a religious holiday if you believe in
giving thanks to a creator
but they hate thanksgiving because they
believe there is nothing you should be
thankful for in america this is an awful
place
it is cancerous rotten to the core tear
it all down
burn it from within why would you be
thankful instead we need
a revolution
remember as the students for a
democratic society radicals once wrote
in the 1960s
they said conflict is the origin of
everything
what happens when you're thankful by
definition you're less likely
to be involved and engaged in conflict
thanksgiving is supposed to de-escalate
any sort of pre-existing
issues in our country
and now they're using the virus as an
excuse for you not to be thankful
we'll be right back now charlie clearly
is just upset that he's still not
allowed to sit at the adult table at
thanksgiving they're keeping him at the
kids table and he's just absolutely
furious
but everything he's saying is completely
untrue the left has never been opposed
to being thankful
the questions about thanksgiving were
never religious they were more about
acknowledging that thanksgiving has
another side to it
just like columbus day which is the
genocide of native americans by early
american settlers
but that's not even the issue here what
i want to remind you
is that the entire war on thanksgiving
thing is not new they're now
so the point here is they now are acting
as though this is a fact-based reaction
to guidelines around
the pandemic a year ago there was no
pandemic
and they were still talking about a war
on thanksgiving check this clip out from
fox news
last thanksgiving more than a year ago
compare their travel plans and dinner
menus for
turkey day otherwise known as
thanksgiving canceled culture
has turned on the holiday the huffington
post seriously suggesting americans skip
spending time with family instead
foregoing travel to save
our planet hitter react comedian michael
loftus michael great to see as always
let's put on a screen the title of this
article it is called the environmental
impact of your thanksgiving dinner
and here's what they want to get rid of
cue full screen
they want to take turkey out of
the turkey dinner because of your carbon
footprint
cut down on travel for both yourself and
your food i'm often interested in my
foods travel
and pare down the endless sides
and apps now when i heard this all
joking aside i got viscerally angry
because to me
this is the latest attempt to tear down
an american tradition
that was fine and didn't need any help
what say you
amen brother cut it out that is not a
skit
that is a real segment from fox news
from last year
here is another fox news segment from
last year
we've heard about the war on christmas
but now college students are declaring a
war on thanksgiving forget the war on
christmas
the left is now going after thanksgiving
this was pizzas the war on thanksgiving
they want to fight a war on thanksgiving
they lost the war on christmas they want
to fight again
pc police well they have a new target
thanksgiving
canceled culture has turned on the
holiday cancel thanksgiving
dinner very sad to announce we have to
cancel thanksgiving
all across america a growing number of
students and professors
claim we need to throw away our turkeys
no turkey
no traveling cranberry sauce and mashed
potatoes are bad for the planet
we need to cancel thanksgiving cancel
thanksgiving telling america america
to cancel cancel thanksgiving
cancel thanksgiving and control how many
kids you have i'm not making this up
so there's a few things going on here
first of all money is being made
by these people just creating anger
among their followers for anything
there's actually lots to be angry about
we have food lines in texas this week in
one of the richest countries in the
world
we have a president who has stopped
doing anything as a global hundred-year
pandemic is raging he's had nothing on
his schedule for a week
we could have health care for everybody
but we don't like there's no
shortage of things to be mad about but
none of that anger would be useful to
the american right
so instead they get people fired up
about these inane
non-issues and conspiracy theories joe
biden stole the election
there's a war on thanksgiving and that
is horrifying but it is a very lucrative
grift for them
and then the irony of it if you can call
it that is that they are actually doing
what they
claim the left is doing in other words
they say the left wants people mad
about either christmas or thanksgiving
or whatever that's not true
they want people mad at the left though
about the non-existent attacks on
christmas and thanksgiving
that they claim exist exist they are
doing
what they falsely claim the left is
actually doing
it's just more projection and it's not
going to stop anytime
soon this episode is sponsored by
bluechew one of the things i make a
priority on the show is not to
perpetuate
stigma for things that don't deserve it
we've talked about mental health we've
talked about many things where we should
all just be respectful adults period and
we would be better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night
even on a full stomach since it's
chewable blue chew is prescribed online
by licensed doctors you don't have to go
to a doctor's office
you don't have to wait in line at a
pharmacy it ships right to your door in
a discrete package
they're made in the usa and since
bluetooth prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pay just five dollars shipping that's
blue
chew.com promo code pacman
to try it totally free bluechu is the
better cheaper
faster choice and we thank them for
sponsoring the david pakman show